Tim commotion Dallas Morning News
columnist ESPN around the horn
contributor and he joins us on the
program
how big a game is the bigger game for
Dallas or the Rams this weekend Tim nice
segue from golden bruise and IPAs thank
you Thank You Danny
it is a bigger game honestly for the
Rams and that's part of the problem the
Cowboys would love to to beat a winning
team one time this season hasn't
happened yet throw in six but everybody
knows no matter what happens Sunday they
go into Philadelphia and win and then
they got to be Washington at home and
they win the East whereas the Rams are
kind of hanging around the edge of the
wild-card they could use the Vikings to
lose a game or two
so realistically divided the the Rams
are much closer to elimination for the
loss Sunday then the sad little Cowboys
are they sad little Cowboys
well they here's what they are they're
they're a team of empty empty yards and
empty dreams did you know when you look
at Doc in Amari and Zeke are the first
first in team history to have 4,000 yard
passer thousand yard rush or thousand
yard receiver you would have thought you
would've thought the triplets might have
done it the 90s you'd have thought Romo
and Dez and DeMarco Murray did it these
guys did it they got three games left to
play and the team of six and seven so
what do all these yards mean they're
first in yards the ninth in scoring they
go up and down the field and they do a
lot of nothing with it well so there
they lead the NFL in third down
percentage I would think that'd be a
really big stat for a teams all these
things seems like they would help don't
they yes he's like this would add up to
more than six and seven but they just
caught a kicker who has missed ten field
goals and he's the only kicker has
missed ten field goals in the last four
years and if you're a team that lost two
games by two points and two games by
four points how much could having a
decent just an average kickers out
if you said to the fans you must miss
the playoffs but you get a new head
coach how do you think cowboy fans would
vote there yeah unless you're telling
them they're going to the Super Bowl
with it yeah they're gonna take that and
I think that's I only think that's the
expectation even though people around
here I'm sure I've watched the Eagles
didn't see that you know you and I are
playing wide receiver for them now that
there is just no confidence the team's
going to do anything and they are more
ready than they've ever been to say
goodbye to a head coach more than
Switzer when things were falling apart
his last year more than campo when they
were going five and eleven three years
in a row there is nothing even you heard
the story about Jason Garrett's showing
a highlight yeah I was gonna ask you
about that Tim okay did he run out of
highlights from this year so he used is
there Roger Staubach in this sizzle reel
to find all the plays he wanted but like
okay that's just to me that's fine
that's just the thing a coach does to
try to get his team going but people are
killing him for that there is nothing
Jason Garrett can do but why do you have
to get them going for facing the Rams on
the road I mean you're facing the Rams
like why do I have to get my team hyped
up for that he shouldn't he shouldn't
but the last two games
you saw them completely fall apart after
opening both games it gets Buffalo in
Chicago 14 play touchdown drive 17 play
touchdown drive all oh they're back yeah
they gave up at least 24 straight points
before they they scored again they just
they fall apart at the first sign of
trouble and they have zero confidence
right now I know that there been reports
that the Cowboys are interested in Urban
Meyer and I spoke to a source had said
that urban is interested in the Cowboys
that he realizes maybe that he's a
little toxic too toxic for college
football right now if he's
to come back in coach but I it still
comes back to I I just don't know how
coveted this job is given the
environment that's there you got talent
there and you got an owner who
desperately wants to win I just I don't
know if it's a great job or not like why
would orbán Meyer want to come back and
get into this that's a good question I
don't know it like you said I think he's
done with college or college is done
with him however you want to view that
but right or wrong but I think he might
want to say look I can never get
advanced Nick Saban's record
championship wise I'm gonna be the
number-two guy this era to him but what
if I go to the NFL and I'm a little bit
successful where he failed how does that
make me hmm where does that put me they
may not view that that way at all but
but he might sure he's thought of it at
some point he you know he obviously
knows e Kelly and he knows a couple
other he knows they have good young
talent and he knows good young talent
around the college game he probably has
the ego to believe I'll put it bringing
a coaching staff I know how to coach the
NFL is going to be that different and
and we will have success because they
have good young players we're not going
to miss all these details that the
current Cowboys missed they're you know
having a bad kick or being last and
kickoff returns never creating turnovers
all the little things they don't do I
think he could see it but you're right
there's a lot of coaches that would stay
away and I've always said I'm gonna line
Lincoln Riley would leave Oklahoma where
he's he's in the big 12 championship the
season begins just question of which TV
is gonna play and which quarterback he's
gonna have you know going to New York
for the Heisman ceremony and then come
here and you know maybe be out in three
years yeah if I'm Lincoln Riley and I
surprised a lot of my audience where I
said I would stay at Oklahoma I get I
would I get paid as well as an NFL coach
I have a couple of games that I have to
win or if you go into the Browns
situation where they're just waiting for
somebody to come in who looks and sounds
like they know what their
doing there but Dallas would make me
nervous as much as there's a great
upside you're never gonna get credit
when you win and you're gonna get blame
when you lose and not many of these
coaches are wired that way and they're
all control freaks and you don't have
total autonomy with that team so yeah
just the fact that if you were the coach
now regardless what we think of Jason
Garrett you have to listen to your owner
general manager talking about Urban
Meyer with three games ago when you're
in first place
yeah if I said you could pick the Super
Bowl matchup ooh
who would you pick ah you know III think
Baltimore's gonna get there I think they
have a great chance to get there I don't
think San Francisco is going to get
there I think it's good I don't think
that's going to happen I think it's if
I'm picking today it's gonna be
Baltimore Green Bay's know what would be
your ideal match up you get to pick do
you really think that Green Bay is gonna
be the team out of the NFC I think no no
I was saying like if you were
programming this what would be the best
matchup for TV oh well edit this out
post the Cowboys in there somehow I mean
you know the Cowboys are the Eagles are
going to the playoffs and it might as
well be the Cowboys but then they got to
win three games but I mean already
talking reality TV or fantasy Jim come
on yeah can you help me here a little
bit I'm struggling with the question I
don't think the Cowboys are going to the
Super Bowl yes I have my choice of all
the eligible teams yeah that are picking
the Cowboys I'm gonna pick Baltimore I
think Lamar Jackson to Baltimore is the
biggest story of the league okay so that
wasn't that hard that's okay yeah I like
a dream matchup but do you think Green
Bay is going to the Super Bowl if I was
picking today I would put them out of
the San Francisco Seattle contingent and
I think the Saints might be falling
apart a bit so I don't think it's going
to be them so I would lean I think the
pack
are very I think they're much more solid
than people think what cities leave at
home games are very tough up there
what's an easier job covering the
Cowboys or being a contributor to around
the horn rather horn is a daily
challenge have you seen some of the
young competitors that I have to
vanquish from time to time though I know
they're they're throwing about new ones
at us every day and yet here I stand 475
wins second highest on the other pyramid
will you ever catch moody page ooh
that's kind of I don't want to say
what's going to require a different show
we'll put it that way but a different
show but that's all Woody Paige has to
live for right is around the hole you
have a lighter bein much more worldly
I've got things in my life you're in
love I listen to sometimes yes I listen
to the symphony channel I've XM serious
76
you're not gonna lot going on yeah I can
tell you live the life ma'am I'm just
happy I knew you win just so I can just
oppose that to somebody you'd like to
see it a Christmas party
you were you were just like the Cowboys
of the 90s you used to be a blast
[Laughter]
have a great weekend have fun covering
another reading thank you Tim and and
happy Holidays to you to you and the day
that's as well thank you that's Tim Cal
show around the horn for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV streamed for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]